so I brought you to the Royal Society of
Chemistry this is the professional
Society for chemists in the UK and some
other countries and we've come here
because I want to see the presidential
badge of office I've heard about it lots
of time but never actually seen it and
it's meant to have all sorts of
interesting elements in the badge itself
so let's go inside and see if we can see
it I've never been down these stairs
before
it's like Alice in Wonderland through
the little dog so we're now in the vault
never been here it's quite quite unusual
it's a tiny room can hardly move in here
and so I've been shown with the
Presidential badges so let's get it out
so here it is let's see what's inside
the box
so this is the badge and the ribbon is
quite interesting because the ribbon
itself is dyed with the sample of moven
which was the first artificial dye that
had ever been made was made by Perkins
he discovered it when he was 18 was a
millionaire by the time he was thirty a
good role model for chemists nowadays
and it was the first day that was ever
been made that was purple
suddenly purple became really
fashionable everybody was wearing purple
clothes and this was in the mid 19th
century and was really the start of the
chemical industry in the United Kingdom
so we'll turn our attention now to the
badge so this is the badge that is worn
by the president of the Royal Society of
Chemistry on the fish'll occasions when
he is being the president so here in the
middle we have Priestley and Priestley
standing inside a hexagon which is meant
to represent benzene really in benzene
all the sides should be exactly the same
length but here you can see it's been
distorted a bit in this direction
because Priestley is taller than he's
fat Priestley was the discoverer of
oxygen though there is some arguments
that the chemist Schaller might have
discovered it at the same time this rim
here like the rim of the cartwheel is
made out of gold and you can see it is a
nice golden color and then all of these
spokes are made from metals and each
spoke is made from a different metal but
the first thing that you can see they
all look pretty much the same because if
a metal isn't colored like gold they all
look shiny in a silvery colour and so
unless you're a specialist you probably
can't tell the difference between them
are there people that could look at
those metals then without doing any
chemistry on them and tell me what they
were made from they're probably some
most people will be able to tell the
difference if they started lifting them
up because some are very much denser
than others tunston for example will be
much denser than zinc and so if you
could actually feel them individually
that they would be much easier to tell
the difference so this one here is
zirconium which is quite a light metal
this is the one that's used for cladding
and nuclear power plants and next to
that is cobalt which is a metal that's
used quite widely and catalysts it's
also used for some sorts of magnets that
are very powerful then after that can't
read what this one is I think this one
is platinum here which is one of the
very valuable metals it's not the most
valuable but one of the most valuable
this one here is nickel which again is
used in some catalysts very finely
divided nickel is used for hydrogenation
catalyst adding hydrogen to organic
compounds and nickel is also interesting
because it was the first metal that was
discovered to react with carbon monoxide
to make a volatile compound it boils at
room temperature think of that a metal
compound that's a gas if you heat it
just above 25 degrees centigrade then
going round here we have titanium
titanium is a very light metal and very
strong and next that that one is iridium
which is another metal similar to
platinum and rhodium it's very expensive
it is using some catalysts it's used in
the catalyst to make ethanoic acid or
acetic acid one of the components of
vinegar by an industrial scale iridium
makes a really good catalyst for this
here we have niobium which is used and
not sure what niobium is useful I think
it can be used to reinforce steel
and it is not nearly as important to
metal as some of the others and then
going round here we have tungsten
tungsten is the highest melting point
metal there is so that one down here is
palladium it's lighter than platinum but
again it's in the same group as the
periodic table as platinum but it is
used quite a lot in catalysis and there
was a belief that perhaps palladium
could catalyze nuclear fusion cause
deuterium atoms to fuse together to
produce energy but there was a lot of
excitement in the early 1980s no sir
late 1980s but now most people feel that
those experiments actually were not very
reproducible and something else was
happening
this one is molybdenum molybdenum is
particularly interesting as it's one of
the few heavy elements which appears in
enzymes then round here we have tantalum
which is the metal that is particularly
used in so-called electrical capacitors
these are tiny components in electronic
circuits which can store electrical
charge for a short time they are a vital
component in making mobile telephones
for example without tantalum you
couldn't have mobile telephones that's
why people are beginning to recycle
mobile telephones so they can recover
some of these metals and finally we come
down to this element here which is
rhodium rhodium is one of the best
metals for catalyzing chemical reactions
you hadn't seen it before what do you
know you've seen it with your own eyes
what do you think of it well I don't
think it's enormous ly beautiful but be
really nice to have my office to teach
students about the
metals somebody told me just killed we
were coming down the stairs that in fact
when this was made about 60 years ago
some of these metal bars were the first
time that that particular metal had ever
been made into a bar so this is really
quite a metallurgical achievement and I
presumably the people who made it learnt
quite a lot about processing some of
these metals do you know anyone who sees
this who isn't a chemist and gets
excited by metals they're gonna have one
question what's it worth I no idea we'll
have to ask the guys from the Royal
Society of Chemistry but I think it will
be worth quite a lot because of the
metals themselves but it's probably the
labor in making this might be quite as
great as the cost of the value of the
metals themselves the person who wears
it is the current president of the Royal
Society of Chemistry at the moment the
president of the Royal Society of
Chemistry is one of my colleagues from
Nottingham Dave garner and it's rather
nice he's a specialist in the chemistry
of molybdenum so he will when he's going
round be wearing a thing with his
favorite element there and so I think
most of the presidents will be able to
find one of their favorite elements
there and those that are organic chemist
of course will have benzene in the
middle and for the physical chemists who
are closer to physics they probably like
it because they can look at the
properties of the different metals you
happy real well yes I did we better put
it back again